يبحث العاملون الطبيون في جميع أنحاء البلاد في
كل مكان عن الإمدادات الأساسية
هذه الأيام ، ربما وجد البعض ما
يبحثون عنه في قبو في
ليفربول نيويورك حيث
يدير ستيفاني كيث وإيزاك
بودمان صناعات Budman ، وعادة ما
يصنع الزوجان طابعات ثلاثية الأبعاد ويشاركان الخطط و
نصائح عبر الإنترنت كجزء من
ثقافة الطباعة المنزلية الدولية تحت الأرض ،
رأينا أشخاصًا يستخدمون طابعات ثلاثية الأبعاد لكل
شيء بدءًا من الأيدي الاصطناعية إلى
المناورات من فيلم Marvel المفضل لديهم
حتى نهاية الأسبوع الماضي ، حيث
بدأ الفيروس الحالي في الانتشار ،
اكتشفوا كيفية صنعه
استغرقت دروع الوجه الطبية مع طابعاتها
بضعة أيام ونصف دزينة من النماذج
الأولية للحصول عليها بشكل صحيح ، أخبرني عن الأقنعة
نفسها ، فنحن نرسل ملفًا ثلاثي الأبعاد إلى
الطابعة وتقوم بطباعة هذا القناع
ويستغرق الأمر حوالي 58 دقيقة على أجهزتنا
لطباعة إسحاق  واشترت ستيفاني
البلاستيك المرن والشفاف اللازم
لإكمال الدروع وتعقيم
متطوعي الاستوديو الخاصين بهم.  خط تجميع مكون
من 16 طابعة تعمل على
مدار الساعة حتى الآن ، لقد قاموا بطرد ما يقرب من
400 قناع مكتمل تم تسليمها جميعًا إلى
قسم إدارة الطوارئ المحلي في
مقاطعة أونونداغا ، يمكننا تسريع عملية
تسوية المنحنى من خلال نشر
هذه التقنية وتوصيل الأشخاص ،
فقد حان الوقت  لقد تم إنفاقها جيدًا ،
فليس فقط مجتمعهم الواقع في شمال
نيويورك هم من يؤثرون ، لقد قاموا أيضًا
بتحويل شبكتهم الاجتماعية أو
هواة الطابعات ثلاثية الأبعاد إلى شبكة من
مصانع الإمدادات الطبية الصغيرة ، وقد
تجاوز هذا فقط
شركتك الصغيرة ومجموعة الطابعات ثلاثية الأبعاد الصغيرة الآن
عندما تم تسليم الدفعة
الأولى فجأة ، بدأنا نسمع من
الأشخاص في جميع أنحاء العالم
المستجيبين الأوائل في جميع هذه المناطق الذين يعانون من
نقص في الإمدادات والذين يحتاجون إلى دروع
في نفس الوقت ، حصلنا أيضًا على
ردود فعل من الأشخاص الذين لديهم
الطابعات ثلاثية الأبعاد حتى يتمكنوا من إنشاء قاعدة بيانات
لربط المحتاجين بالآخرين باستخدام
طابعة ثلاثية الأبعاد والرغبة في مساعدة وجوههم حتى الآن
انخفض عدد ماسك أو ماتيك بما
يقرب من 2000 ضعف عدد
طلبات الأقنعة
وفقًا لصناعات بوب مينه وهو أكثر
من 40.000 د.  قدمت المغذيات وجارا
أحد تلك الطلبات
التي تعمل في أحد
أكبر مستشفيات مدينة نيويورك حتى أنها تضطر إلى
طلب المساعدة من مصادر غير تقليدية في
هذه المرحلة ، نحن ندرك أنه لا أحد
يأتي لإنقاذنا ونحن كمجتمع
على مستوى القاعدة  يجب أن تبدأ في
التعبئة للاستفادة من جميع الموارد
التي نعرفها في وقت ما ،
ربما ستبدأ الحكومة الفيدرالية
وقنوات التوريد ولكن ليس
بالقدر الكافي وليس في القريب العاجل
حتى ذلك الحين سيتعين على المستشفيات والعاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية
الاعتماد على الأمريكيين
براعة وأشخاص مثل إسحاق
وستيفاني أعتقد أنه كان جون كنيدي هو الذي قال
لا تسأل عما يمكن أن تفعله دولتك من أجلك
ولكن ما يمكنك فعله
لبلدك وفي هذه اللحظة نشعر أنه يمكننا
القيام بذلك لأفراد بلدنا يفعلون
ما في وسعهم  بالنسبة لجيرانهم
ليس بالأمر الجديد سوى صنع الأجهزة الطبية
في المنزل لأن المستشفيات لا تستطيع الحصول عليها
في الوقت الحالي وهذا هو الوضع الطبيعي الجديد
Evan McMorris santoro CNN New York